how about this individual effort that goes
straight to the Highlight Reel this might
be up for goal of the Year dealing Json with a
backand wide of the goal here's kzo around the
Chicago net out the near side Andre kzo spinning
on in front the score shter and that emotional
reaction was a thank you to Andre kusco for a
spinning pass through the slot and all Su had
to do was pop it in to make it want nothing this
is what K can do so well get some separation eyes
to the back they had the old spinner Suter buries
in as moric stretches across and goes under him
remaining in the second Peli Robertson his shot
he scores the defenses of the Islanders at times
have looked like they're thinking more than doing
Stars used that to their advantage just squeeze
it into the slot the sly slippery play of Jason
Robertson eloquently from his skate to his stick
to Elevation and a tie hockey game leaps now
with 94 point of chance from scores Matthews
just following in middle and how about these
hands between the legs and Joey dor tried to
get that left pad out as far as he could but look
at the patience by Matthews he had about the size
of a puck available there between the skate and
the post and he was able to put it right where
he needed [Applause] to Hawk Zone here trying to
help defend Quinn tapping that s score shot from
a the goal line on the far side of the Ice by
PKA slauer boom is off the side of the net he's
got it tight there's nothing there but it goes
right off the side of his head and because of
the angle he had his helmet on he directs it
into the back of the net talk about your fire
Puck not try to be precise he was trying to be
precise there and he nailed it in the standings
Here Comes Ro moud and his the outlet pass from
the defensive Zone this catches McLoud in speed
as it can't be handled in tight by Fogle and
just kind of ricochets right to him he elevates
short side up over top of the glove hand side of
lar Flyers break it up Frost holding on slips it
across for York York the shot blocked and then he
backs it and he SCS little baseball skill from C
YK backand out of it air and pass basil following
that F all the way around waits till it gets below
the crossbar that's what amazes me and he sees it
the whole time whacking that thing top shelf what
a beauty it looked like he was headed off and now
peels back here's a guy that can scoop to Nikolai
eers breaking in on C to the back hand scores and
how about this individual effort head up flying a
little move there dances around shik kicks it to
a stick and then that beautiful backand as well
to finish off just inside the post and it had
a lot of mustard on it Greer flips that back in
kicked away picked up by Matthews in scores
this is the brilliant of Austin Matthews he
just jumps on this loose Puck that's not clear
drags it through his legs and that rer as good
as there is Greer's trying to dump it in it gets
kicked back towards him keeps it on S side swats
it has that touch threw his legs then away from
oerly and straight into the Wheelhouse to beat
Vadar in with more chances nice drag gorgeous
move a shot score a thing of beauty for from
Wyatt Johnston that goes straight to the Highlight
Reel well Wyatt went bear back here he just tow
drag loses one fights off a Jack and then with
do in full Retreat is able to slip it past the
glove oh and tip it turbocharge time tippet
spins back at he SC oh and Tipp it absolutely
dazzling oh my goodness what a goal I thought
he'd go wide initially he goes wide cuts to
the middle and then the spin and he absolutely
rips the backand as well he's a big man he's in
full flight and this is a hot nasty spinorama
six school backand that was absolutely filthy
and it's going to go crazy online this might be
up for goal of the year slowsky has got it sovi
will dump it in out of the net is Dos merer
after it offield knocks it out the air fronts
lovsky scores what set up by Cole Coffield and
slap kovski finishes it watch Coffield turn the
stick over in midair and bat it backwards with
the toe you know he gets in the comfort spot and
he puts it right onto the Stick of slab kovski
snoa comes up with the PO has to move snoa in CS
to a slot drop hear Joseph on a set up by snoa
it's Tim sputa with a stop back play chips it
to himself and then a reverse right to Matthew
Joseph who skates right into it creates a lane
for himself decides that Matthew Joseph is the
better Lane pops it to him and we've got a 5-1
lead Barby ahead and now the pass into the
middle and in on go walk for the shot and he
scored what a rush up the ice Tic Tac Toe the
area pass Walker the Finish incredible Vision
by Morgan Frost and creativity I mean this is
an allor play by Frost use the walls right up
to frost he knows that Walker Off to the Races
backhand touch Walker with a perfectly placed
shot to the blocker side this is a blue team that
can catch in short-handed they've got nine shorty
this season oh she dangles it's SC a snapshot
darts from TJ o I love everything about the
goal the work to get to the middle to beat the
defender on one knee and then the shot under the
bar for TJ for the doubles jackets looking to
avenge that here tonight centering pass scores
go cyinder sends it off the goal post it in the
speed of power of chikov here as he gets through
but he's going to followup display and it's a
beautiful little chop pass a no look area play
to singer who slows things down gets in that open
space and as he does that rolling talk he says I'm
not going to settle this down I'm just going to
throw it at the n and that's a nice celebration
here to start this one the Stars spring it ahead
for HS again short-handed drag to the inside he
scores a gorgeous goal what a slick Against the
Grain just leave it back the goal tender Nico dos
allowed him to eat him off thinking he was going
to sweep in front maybe elevate a back back hand
he just leaves it against the Green a Dandy for
rope and an enormous tally back to Center IO sha
n will look to move it in now throw to the front
a chance and a go Clayton ker and he might have
taking a shot up high as well Tommy Shan dery is
not feeling it the spinner look at this play right
here on net Dylan got there finds Keller back
door and is that beautiful right onto the tape
two Beauty pass by both dery and Gunther Co BS the
shot takes it behind the net and Maran has his 20
goals Montreal makes a cardinal mistake trying
to make a lateral pass in the defensive Zone
through a for check and how about the strength
and balance of Charlie Coyle he wanted to turn
and shoot but that was taken away from him so he
pushed to the right uses to the net able to get
around the goal marshan gets open in the slot
nobody picks him up for the Montreal Canadians
maran's not going to miss from there saan Jad long
pass off for [__] crder save by doall again and
he scores on the rebound what a pass out of the
zone to lead krider krider goes right to the net
gets his own rebound and just chips it over the
goenda there it is again and then off the Stick
of Henrik and there you see henrik's frustration
COV to point COV again headman back to COV he's
in back to Hond score a great feed by coov and the
finish by Victor Hedman beautiful little drop play
Hedman gets involved the Chris Cross just when
you think cof's got enough room gives it back
to Victor Hedman the puck has eyes going through
everybody's feet lion ends up face down on that
one suer will play it back in kie on it BL to the
front they score Jason sucker and he was set up
beautifully by the Pittsburgh kid Logan [__]
look at the play there by Logan coie he turns
his stick over and just shovels that puck across
and how about the finish by zooker little Chip
Shot over the blocker and once again the coties
are off and running and get that all in one first
goal up top Carlson back for Crosby chops it in
you cannot stop him you can only hope to contain
him and that is so patented Crosby just when you
think he can't do it der's right on him too from
a impossible angle what touch what a goal look
at that smile he's having a good time turned
over sharks headed for a second Byfield with it
Byfield along the wall with some nice moves out
to England right side to Spence and back in down
low Kee a man in front he's center Shot score
the spacing how many times have we seen this
where the three guys down low will not crowd
each other but then the man who hangs back and
we see Quint Byfield working on this shot every
day at practice sometimes down to one knee it
doesn't matter what timer back of the [Music] N